[Music]
how have you been how's how are you
doing you know i'm good i'm good i'm
very well i i just came uh you know i
was uh in uh in new york hosting senate
line for the first time and you did an
amazing job
did an amazing job
thank you
really
well like
like jessica simpson spanx it's all
about holding up under pressure and i
think that
no it's weird you know that i mean it
never changes i mean i was on that show
um in the 80s and it's exactly the same
you get there your heart is pounding
there's the same
smell of of competition and hatred
toward each other i mean it's it's the
strength that keeps that show together i
think you also had an amazing week
because uh your musical guest is paul
mccartney paul mccartney sir paul
mccarthy yes
yes
that's a sweet
it's a sweet gig for a week it really is
and and we it was so bizarre because you
know
you know you you you see the guy all
week and and you can never get over
sometimes how famous someone is and at
one point we were in rehearsing and you
know he he's a real musician he wants to
just sing all the time
and even at the at one o'clock at the
end of that show he did four more
beatles songs so the audience went crazy
and and so but we were in rehearsal and
uh
at one point they were calling for
dinner and he said he started
then he says marty sing with me and
suddenly i'm singing with paul mccartney
and the mics right here fortunately i
didn't know any of the lyrics of the
song but had i know
it's the easiest one i know they say
birthday over and over and over i know
but still i was floundering it wasn't
like if like if frank sinatra junior it
said sing weather-wise is it such a
cuckoo i could do that right but no no
but you're you know there are times when
you meet famous like you've met
presidents yes i've met presidents and
kings and jugglers how many presidents
have you met
uh let's see that's a good question i've
met several presidents i believe well i
guess they'll be doing some edit at this
point to the show will it what are you
talking about
just give us a name i i uh president uh
clinton president obama i met george w
bush
at the white house and up close i
realized that he looked like a
beautifully quaffed simeon
[Laughter]
she said welcome to my house
it was very sweet but then remember my
arm was around laura and i didn't know
how she was wearing there was like
revealed flesh and i didn't know how
close to put my hand so i kept it above
her shoulder i didn't want to start you
know copping a fuel with the first lady
that's very classy of you thank you yeah
you know that uh no that was uh so
that's the is that the biggest star
you've met then i mean the the big stars
you've met paul mccartney and me there's
a few where you get
oh no you get to a certain level where
you break through you look more irish by
the way every time i see you you look
like the the film negative of django
unchained
[Applause]
[Music]
is there any blood in you i get more
irish every time you see it's
unbelievable the last little bit of
blood has clearly been sucked from your
sister
years ago
you bet i am irish yes the thing is you
are as irish as i yeah i somehow look uh
more and more ridiculous to you
you're just interpreting me but my
father was actually born and raised in
cross mclean county armagh he i grew up
with a rogue marty get down here you
know that thing he would yell at you
marty come down here marty what if i was
late for church right defy thee the lord
okay come on come on come on come on
always mass every week you know i made a
conversation a long time ago people
think that irish people sort of talk
like the lucky charms out of like oh you
better not but in real life you can't
understand what they're saying
[Music]
what are they talking about